[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon faculty colleagues
families friends and students I welcome
you to the 317th commencement of Yale
University and to the 157th anniversary
of the date on which Yale conferred its
first and the nation's first PhD degree
today we celebrate our students
accomplishments as scholars and
researchers and we award the degrees
earned by their dedication to the
advancement of human knowledge we are
extremely proud of all that you have
achieved in your time at Yale and we
thank you for your contributions to your
fields congratulations to you all
to begin today's ceremony I want first
to recognize those graduate students and
faculty who received prizes at
yesterday's convocation your programs
list the student at student academic
prizes right now at this time I ask all
student prize winners who are present to
stand so that we can again congratulate
you on your achievement
and yesterday a convocation for the 20th
time the graduate mentor Awards
celebrated faculty members who have been
outstanding teachers and advisors of
graduate students the three faculty
members who received the award this year
exemplify the many important qualities
to which all graduates teachers should
aspire at this time I asked our mentor
Prize winners in attendance today to
stand so that we can again recognize
their achievements
these three faculty represent all the
faculty who have helped you navigate
graduate school you have also been
supported by many others on campus whose
labor and loyalty contribute to make
Yale the distinguished University it is
let me name a few and then we can clap
for all of them the university's
custodial and maintenance staff make you
look so beautiful and keep us in good
condition all year the dining hall staff
feed us today at commencement and
throughout the year the clerical
technical staff conduct the university's
business with acumen and dispatch the
managerial and professional staff direct
and administer our departments and
schools and we could not get here
without them and spits it and I also
recognize the staff of the Graduate
School who sustain the institution with
which within which Yale graduate
education thrives for all of these women
and men of Yale I ask for your
recognition through applause from all of
us in the room
finally I also ask you to acknowledge
the super musical abilities of our
organist today mr. David fun Byron one
of the many accomplished students at the
Yale School of Music who is playing on
one of the world's great pipe organs
here in Woolsey Hall
[Applause]
it is customary for the Dean at this
time to make brief remarks and to make
them enclosing at the end of the of the
ceremony however today I must change
that custom just a bit not in terms of
brevity but in terms of order in
addition to enjoying my fourth
commencement as Dean of the Graduate
School I'm also the proud parent of a
graduating college senior fortunately
here at Yale rather than some far-flung
place like California or Texas so I hope
you will excuse me in a few minutes so I
can see her receive her diploma in
Davenport one of Yale's 14 residential
colleges just a few blocks from here but
don't worry
but don't worry I leave you in very good
hands of the very good hands of
Professor Thomas Pollard my predecessor
as Dean of the Graduate School and the
Dean with whom many students here began
their Yale careers he is graciously here
today to congratulate our graduates and
give them their diplomas after I leave
I hope before I go I have a few words
for all of you our graduates candidates
for the PhD the unfill and master's
degrees before we begin the honor of
conferring your your degrees I know for
many of you getting to this graduation
day has not been easy but you have
prevailed you have taken advantage of
all yellow graduate school offers as you
pursued your studies and scholarly
research during your time with us you
have learned that the way of research
and scholarship is neither
straightforward nor always smooth a line
of inquiry inquiry may take you nowhere
and months of work could bear no fruit
an experiment could go awry and you find
yourself back at square one you don't
need to be told that graduate study
takes inspiration but also hard work and
especially perseverance and
determination learning to continue in
the face of challenges characterizes the
ability to do advanced research and the
fact that you're still here today means
that you have learned that lesson today
you leave Yale as thinkers explorers
creators teachers and as many of you
heard at our recent where do I go from
Yale day you also leave with a set of
skills that equip you for a range of
careers your innovative and critical
thinkers problem solvers leaders team
players and effective communicators
poised to launch fulfilling careers
whatever direction you choose to apply
your skills of advanced learning let
your accomplishments inspire you to
tackle new challenges with the
confidence that you have the skill to
navigate all difficulties as a Yale
graduate you are all given the
opportunity to contribute to society and
to make a difference in your field of
study as you go forth I hope that you
will also stay engage
and in touch with us as alumni and
consider mentoring those who follow in
your footsteps it has been my privilege
to lead the graduate schools effort to
provide you with the environment in
which you grew into the scholars you are
today I am proud of what you have
accomplished and excited to see what you
will do next
well now begin the awarding of graduate
degrees and this is how it will work
we'll call the graduates to the stage by
department or program in which they've
earned their degrees for those students
receiving more than one degree not to
worry all diplomas will be awarded
together Dean and Galen will read the
citations and please come forward as
your name is called to congratulate the
degree recipients we will be joined at
the front of the stage by faculty
members from each department or program
and yes you may applause whenever you
see fit there were times when such a
pause for individual graduates was
thought a little bit impolite but we
welcome it I now pass the diploma
ceremony into the hands of professor and
dean emeritus Tom Pollard with my thanks
to the graduates and their families I
give my warmest congratulations to the
parents here I understand the pride you
must have in your graduate and trust you
will understand why I am rushing out the
door to see my daughter get her diploma
congratulations
[Applause]
african-american studies Danielle
Bainbridge PhD
[Applause]
for the PhD african-american studies
tina post
[Applause]
African Studies ma Botes killer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
marade and Monroe
[Applause]
Garrett Joseph notch
[Applause]
American Studies for the PhD anna
karenina Kournikova montiel juliet
Nebulon the MA Amanda dire shemish
[Applause]
anthropology for the PhD Samar al
Belushi
[Applause]
dorsa amir sonic oh Sh
[Applause]
Rose K timing
[Applause]
Caroline grace Mary felt
[Applause]
Gabrielle Alisa Moreland
[Applause]
who's not shaken Islamic Colin T Thomas
[Applause]
Daniella woollen Andrew Wommack for
Applied Physics the PhD Kevin
Xu Lai Chau
[Applause]
Eric new Aki Jin
[Applause]
let go
Venus
[Applause]
Anirudh gnarley'
[Applause]
for the MPhil Marius Constantine
[Applause]
for the MS Logan Phillips
[Applause]
for archeological studies the MA
Matthew Jonathan Longhorn
[Applause]
Karimi Elizabeth Valdez
Ava Noel wells architecture for the PhD
teams Tim Stefan alcohol i na buco
[Applause]
standard blue or Rossi michael serese
labs astronomy for the PhD
Jeremy D Bradford Duncan Alan Campbell
[Applause]
Allison Taylor Merritt Joseph Randle
Schmidt cell biology shinu long
[Applause]
so we Jeong jinwu
ciao Carlina June Kauffman Katherine
Krueger Christopher Kon May June May
our room Julie Park you Michael Valery
Taguchi manga
[Applause]
for the MPhil Amanda Jane vine
[Applause]
Nancy morones for cellular and molecular
physiology the PhD carl walther barbour
[Applause]
branded mark caso a chemistry for the
PhD ying-ying tied Shawn Michael cold
Calvin
[Applause]
Stephanie more silly cray
Oh God or lava Patrick Joseph Keller
[Applause]
shall on Lee
[Applause]
Wayne you
Kelly materna Eric Pierce Troutman Cory
Eric para Kevin Patrick
Regan Benjamin brutish sting Leo Shang
Xiang Ying hosen Demeter Yakov shuffle
[Applause]
Julie coronal and health and Claire
[Applause]
Shashi Bhushan Sinha
[Applause]
Joseph Tyler watts in ski Allison Sarah
Walker
[Applause]
Shinyoung page' um
[Applause]
min-soo that Ryan Matthew Davis for
classics the PhD Shara Darren bow Karl
Matthew Keller
[Applause]
Claudia part Portugal Oh Tom Jew Alex
Jung
[Applause]
for comparative literature Sauron
Forsberg
we're reliable
[Applause]
for computational biology and
bioinformatics Stefan Philippe Evvie
[Applause]
Jennifer Christine game Chang Tao Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
Seong Yun
[Applause]
jeonhwa
[Applause]
for computer science Ross Liske in the
Masters of Science cheats ow ken-chan
[Applause]
you Joe Chan
[Applause]
chin wink whoa
Shuchi ho
[Applause]
Brian hi
Archy whoo
[Applause]
kwan/wong
[Applause]
Jenna Angie Nancy John John Young Jiang
[Applause]
Lin Chang Jiang Shi Cheng Chao Xiao
[Applause]
Cheng Li Jie Shin Yu how soon
[Applause]
Wang dong Xue
how ironic Wang Yu Wang Geon woo
[Applause]
kai young
[Applause]
in Beijing
[Applause]
angel jang yi-jeong you shall jack
[Applause]
the lien job
[Applause]
you John that's you
ciao banjo
[Applause]
East and Asian languages and literatures
Riley Parker Souls PhD Justine Kirby
Weisinger for the MA
Aaron die
[Applause]
at Alexandria hero honey
chu un quoi for ecology and evolutionary
biology for the PhD
Elizabeth garlic spring for economics
for the PhD Noriko
Georgina Amano patina
[Applause]
valia beer Johnny each end
[Applause]
Giovanni campeones Matthew Oliver home
Monica
Morlock
[Applause]
[Music]
table I don't know almost
[Applause]
annamaria
Reynoso here are no Ruiz Sanchez
[Applause]
Lujan woo
Vitor Augusto possible waiting men
I am punch Barney
[Applause]
for the MA Chooch one she Engineering
and Applied Science and we'll do this
one by program for the program in
biomedical engineering for the PhD arena
corn Ava Nina
Kristin Krista fake Aaron H Morin Andres
Minos Rojas
Amanda spot pelo CA lean red
Jonas chuan naive Wang Eva jungle
[Applause]
Margaret Elise bulla for the MS
[Applause]
Alexander Jocelyn Adrian l-'azim legs
Azima Mendoza
Chanyeol in Shin low
Andrew L Moreno ha how you young for the
program chemical and environmental
engineering for the PhD
Dhruva Jody Deborah Zachary Schwartz
Fishman
[Applause]
gilad house money
[Applause]
Amanda Winston Lounsbury John Terrence
power when boshi
[Applause]
Anthony Stroh
Zhu Xiao Tong Sheng Shi Zhang
[Applause]
are you Lua or Lucy no answer for
electrical engineering the PhD
minashi Chatterjee NAT bomb
[Applause]
Chea whoa and child
[Applause]
first John Harsanyi
four shutouts on you oh yeah moe
sir Rama Murali Dhara me brush para
julie michelle baseman for the FL way
full
[Applause]
Cara Esfandiari
[Applause]
I asked uh Fernando
[Applause]
mechanical engineering and material
science the PhD Hoonah dot board Anita
casting in Konya
[Applause]
Omar aired in dr. Ian
[Applause]
GT tah-dah they go
we should more version Ison Niraj Julia
Kathryn Sullivan
Alejandro beretta Ming Lee Wong for the
Emma Sebastian Alexander Kubek
[Applause]
English language and literature for the
PhD Karla Barrett
[Applause]
Jason Eric Bell
[Applause]
Palmer rhabdo
Josh whole Samuel Stanley
[Applause]
Anna Costello barrini Elizabeth Francis
Lazzari European and Russian studies VMA
hi Rocha Daria
[Applause]
sergej rubbish
hiya ethical Ian Zita coke
[Music]
[Applause]
Charles Robert Henry little one
[Applause]
Kyle Chapman Mancuso Patrick McNeil
Jeffery Michael
[Applause]
Maria who's the bear
[Applause]
Kamilah orlova show me Alexis Pinkerton
[Applause]
for experimental pathology the PhD
Nicole Elizabeth Calabro shall meet you
[Applause]
for forestry and environmental studies
Matthew beard Archer the PhD Gabriel
bozhe wrong
[Applause]
Matt Lambert
Sara Randall
[Applause]
Michael W stone
Timothy Michael turn way Nicky Springer
[Applause]
for French for the PhD Catherine la cour
Dean cheap Chabot Rob Gail front Lucia
wrong go for genetics the PhD Charles
Jonathan Hernandez
[Applause]
Natalya Shiloh pison Katherine Evans
McManus
[Applause]
Kristiana
maria aleyne opinion Oh Christine Rodan
[Applause]
[Music]
Santiago Viveiros Salazar Audrey Turchin
[Applause]
MPhil Stephen Paniagua
[Applause]
for geology and geophysics for the PhD
Ross Peter Anderson
Eric Benoit shower June Chen Dima :
[Applause]
Christopher Gary cruzi Chuang drum minam
Joe
[Applause]
the MPhil michael hansen
[Applause]
Germanic languages and literatures for
the PhD Sophie ELISA rosenheim Oh Nadine
schwa cough William Stovall
[Applause]
for history the PhD when don't need Leia
are ejected
congratulations Alice Lucile Baumgartner
John Murphy's sport burden
Maura Hamilton Keating
Andra grossie
Justin
[Applause]
Marie Emily George must watch them
[Applause]
Holly neo block jeez
Tiffany Hale
we chose McElroy Johnson white test
Lanzarote
and Reena try
[Applause]
Charles Maximilian Walden
Amy Elizabeth Watson
[Music]
Gabriel Emmet why now
[Applause]
Catherine Leah younger
[Applause]
Emma voices GMA Amy
fire
George please Joseph George leach
Matthew Shaffer for history of Arts
for the PhD in history of art Julia
Christine love
[Applause]
Sequoyah Miller
Laurel auric Patterson James Adam
Rodriguez Pablo Ferrara
[Applause]
for immune of biology for the PhD Omo
Tukey a joke ain't a road joke Chris
Drago mr. niche Chow Lou
[Applause]
Michael Todd Parker William ruff Junior
[Music]
Wei Zhi Jing way son Daniel the girl
Louise may Elgin D for the program in
interns remarks departmental
neuroscience the PhD Kaylee and Carla
carullo sorry Clark Oh Sarah Marie
catracha Aaron Levie
[Applause]
Daniel Lee
he'd only
[Applause]
Yasmine Zeki Neos for international and
developmental economics the master's
degree
Emilia abu-salha Cameron RF a deal
Shameka baatein and weecha Barataria one
your child here in catching two yen
wrong John norio she fuku oka
[Applause]
chiaki Ungowa
[Applause]
Ross was cute
throw up email
typhoon come and Elinor cable are you
Chacon
[Applause]
leadership rate in young career room
Rutan Mariana son
[Applause]
Monza saxena our Ellis Schwartz lot
cheese thing John deal Bouchon who Kylie
yeah
schway onion shall jo-jo
[Applause]
for Investigative medicine the PhD Shawn
Evan groom bomb for Italian for the PhD
allison marie Hagley for linguistics the
PhD Greg Anthony Cataloochee Sara
Sanchez Alonso Natalie
Margaret shrimp for management the PhD
giddy applause who sockos
John Charles Peter Chang Feng Dennis
Matthew Greg Lee
[Applause]
guarantor Ozzy Jane Arya and Subramanya
[Applause]
chin pun June whoa
Gyeongju you
[Applause]
for mathematics
for the PhD Daniel Joseph Cory Daniel
Monte Alegre wet new pun G Feng Shang
[Applause]
that ping Wang for the Medieval Studies
the PhD Aaron James Benitez
[Applause]
for Microbiology for the PhD Danielle
Elizabeth Lyons Nikolas Gaurav Benson
Erin Gabriel Wexler for the MPhil
Monique M Richards
[Applause]
for molecular biology biophysics and
biochemistry for the PhD Daniel von
diesen Erin Elizabeth Duffy
Sophia Manasseh as we know the Sanchez
Marsh good my Michael martini lacy
[Applause]
Caroline Wetherington right
[Applause]
Madeline Sherlock Daniel William Emily
Victoria
John Patrick O'Brien the third for the
MS Taylor Lucia self molecular cellular
and developmental biology for the PhD
Karla Carly Samantha Cox
[Applause]
Gregory Alisa Muhammed - beep I'm
[Applause]
jameelah salami
[Applause]
even they're not
Elizabeth Molly
Scott
sheera stop Paul Whitehead deceased
accepting his diploma on his behalf is
his wife
Dorinda of whitehead
[Applause]
Rachel flapper trick Xavier 40 yo MS
for the great degree in music the PhD
analyse her Linda Edgard under ease
[Applause]
Stephen Paul Lera Marissa and plenteous
more
Andrew sharkman DL Polly Elizabeth Chow
[Applause]
Near Eastern languages and civilizations
the PhD Maria Gutierrez
Yesi Cuban Nicholas Larry Krauss Jeffrey
Mosley
Michael a Rappaport fiancée
Salva Paulo for the degrees in nursing
for the PhD Eileen Marie I'm sorry
Eileen Mary condom Caitlin Elise reckon
Burt pally
rupal for pharmacology
for the PhD Chad Jay Miller
[Applause]
Elizabeth mo Tamaki Sasaki
[Applause]
Joshua Jo Kothari
[Applause]
for philosophy for the PhD am Allah
Pamela eats Corcoran
[Applause]
Samuel binky
Elgin Emily I'm sorry Emily Nancy kress
[Applause]
Matthew Alexander my finger for physics
for the PhD MEA alguna Jeremy Stein
Cushman
[Applause]
Stephon Alexander Arlington Devon Wanko
[Applause]
arianna Hackenberg
singly Anthony Lullo David Robert Mason
[Applause]
DMA H Meltzer
Alexander Rivera being jr. Rory boon for
the MPhil Tyler lose for political
science for the PhD
Viva Tina Lavanya our show
[Applause]
[Music]
Cassandra Maya Burch ler
[Applause]
Lucas
Eduardo Intel Joshua
Ross Goodman
you Lee
[Applause]
Paul Lyndon Riddick
[Applause]
Daniel Masterson
[Applause]
Patrick Robert O'Brien
[Applause]
Natalia bueno
Jerome Pablo Schaffer for psychology
for the PhD Richard ah Adam Adam
checkers Rebecca when port gun
Jillian Jordan
[Applause]
Elizabeth teeth Nealon Kathleen and
Altman hannah elizabeth rila andre andre
up now
[Applause]
Amanda blue Zeitlin for the EM Phil
Gordon Croft
Todd for Public Health
for the PhD Briana Christine camera
[Applause]
Michelle Lynn DeVoe
[Applause]
Raul Hernandez Ramirez Jacqueline
right white cute Oh
[Applause]
Tai Chi Yong Jang Yi Liu
[Applause]
Kelsey Burke Linder Catherine a be ours
[Applause]
Benjamin Richard Jumanji
[Applause]
see Dwayne Whittaker Jing Zhi ten search
um
the DMS died way
when G like Lily Jolie you want young
you
[Applause]
Isabel Prada
Uschi
we're almost there folks
Jai cheese son T G wait Aang
[Applause]
young emo John Young
[Applause]
for religious studies
for the PhD Laura Katherine Carlson
[Applause]
Aleksandra Gordeeva Alison a frou-frou
Zeki
Jonathan a Samuel Jonathan Brock
[Applause]
for sociology for the PhD
elizabeth-jane Becker Andrew Connolly
Cohen Isabel he long
[Applause]
way low
William Matthew macmillan Michael Sierra
Arevalo Samuel DeMuth Stabler
Luke Eugene Wagner
[Applause]
for Spanish and Portuguese
for the PhD
in Altos Bruce winter maxi Stephanie
were nerdstore Neola Jose Ramon Sabine
let's dial
[Applause]
for statistics and data science
for the PhD
would William damn it bring down a
second
Jason Kluszewski
[Applause]
you know
yeah Joe
[Applause]
for statistic
for the pH for the ma baby Chung
[Applause]
Stephen Morris Daniel do you go
Felix Philip Yordan you wave John shadi
kuba Li Jie Jie Margaret Lua Cameron
Pringle
[Applause]
one Qian Ren Jonathan Kenan Sehun Daniel
Adam Schneider Sarah
Kokila venkatramana
[Applause]
the leeway
yes our champion
so every year for various reasons it
happens that some of our students are
not able to sit with your departments
and come forward for their diplomas in
the usual order so now ladies and
gentlemen we award final degrees to left
it's that which in some cases may not
appear in the program so in electrical
engineering for the Masters science
khazneh Esfandiari
in psychology for the PhD rosana summer
[Applause]
let me add my congratulations to all the
graduates and let me congratulate my
colleague whoa lots of feedback let me
congratulate my colleague and Galen for
a remarkable performance reading more
than 400 names oh wow
[Applause]
us so now I ask as I call each degree
for the recipients of that degree to
stand to remain standing and after which
I will ask after which I will ask
everyone to congratulate all of our
graduates collectively for their
marvelous achievements so one group at a
time Harris stand to remain standing
Masters of Arts
stand up okay
[Applause]
masters of science
[Applause]
masters of Advanced Studies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
temperamental thing here master
philosophy and finally a doctor of
philosophy everybody should be standing
right now
[Applause]
okay it sounds like we're having trouble
with the mic can you hear now yes we're
good let's hope we don't get that
feedback again so graduates keep
standing because we have a special
tradition here we recognize that time
and effort and attention required to
receive an advanced degree is only
possible with the participation of
support of our families and friends I
would therefore invite all of our degree
recipients who are standing here to turn
to the audience and give them a big
round of applause for their help
okay thank you could be seen it now now
I would like all of us to give special
thanks to two groups of people have
provided the funds for our graduate
studies first let me recognize 300 years
of generous donors who have endowed this
great University
now income from our endowment funds
about half of Graduate Studies at Yale
University
sorry about that the mic is being
temperamental let me thank in particular
in addition to all these donors over 300
years of history to the Gruber Family
Foundation which in 2011 made the
largest gift in the history of the
graduate school to support studies in
the Natural Sciences some of our yeah
some of our graduates here today have
been supported by their funds
[Applause]
second I'd like to thank everybody in
the room for paying their taxes since
federal grants and fellowships fund
research in the natural and Social
Sciences including about half of the
total cost of graduate education at Yale
so thanks to all of you
[Applause]
graduates and their families and friends
together with the faculty and staff or
with us are invited to a picnic lunch
immediately following the conclusion of
this ceremony it will be in the
courtyard at the hall of Graduate
Studies and in the common room at the
hollow graduate study so please join us
for this special picnic after the
ceremony now our cross that you're all
remain in your seats while the platform
party recesses have a fun day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]